so you are looking at the project for
this course notice how it's not
responsive at all at the ends of lessons
two four and five you'll be challenged
to improve this site's responsiveness I
want to make it super super clear that
there is no right solution to this
challenge you'll hear us repeat
throughout the course that responsive
design is an art not a science to
improve your responsive design skills
you'll just have to practice I'll be
talking through the decisions we made in
the steps we took to make this site
responsive and I really don't expect
your answers to look anything like ours
this course is all about thinking
responsively sure we want you to walk
away with a few new CSS tricks up your
sleeves but more importantly I want you
to walk away
approaching responsive design from the
right mindset I'm recording this video
now after having spent several months
working with Pete on this course over
this time I've actually learned quite a
bit I done some responsive work before
but I hadn't approached my sites the way
that you'll be learning in a few minutes
a few weeks into filming I decided to
revamp my personal site and this is what
I came up with now I know it isn't the
prettiest thing in the world but it's
nicely responsive and believe it or not
this website actually only took a few
hours to build over a weekend it wasn't
too bad what helped is that I approached
responsiveness systematically from the
start instead of just as an afterthought
all of this is to say that thinking
responsibly is a huge help for your web
development so are you ready to get
started are you excited to get
responsive let's get started